.
- Ce cinéma de Toronto aborait
les couleurs de la Matrice pour
la grande première du nouveau
film de la série.
Il y avait un air de déjà-vu
pour Keanu Reeves.
Le premier film de la série
"La Matrice" a vu le jour
il y a plus de 20 ans.
Il s'agissait d'une véritable
révolution cinématographique
parce qu'on avait jamais vu de
tels effets spéciaux au ralenti
et des combats en apesanteurs
où des caméras tournaient
autour des acteurs.
MIKAEL DAMANT-SIROIS, V-p.
Opérations créatives, Rodeo FX
- Pour des gens de
ma génération, en fait, ça nous
a beaucoup, beaucoup influencés,
impressionnés, puis moi,
en fait, ça a beaucoup...
ça a été un événement qui m'a
orienté dans ma carrière
et amené à aller dans
les effets numériques.
- La Matrice a remporté quatre
Oscars dont celui des meilleurs
effets spéciaux. Mais
"La Matrice" a aussi marqué
les esprits avec son histoire
d'un monde où les machines
contrôle virtuellement
l'esprit des humains.
ÉRIC FALARDEAU
Réalisateur de cinéma
- La Matrice on pourrait dire
qu'aussi réactualise de grandes
traditions philosophiques
occidentales, d'une part
justement, l'idée que ce que
nous percevons n'est pas
nécessairement vrai. Donc c'est
toute une tradition
philosophique qui vient avec ça.
Il y a ensuite celle du libre
arbitre. Donc, on peut comparer
un peu la Matrice à cette idée
de Descartes dans les
"Médidathysiques"
sur l'idée du mauvais génie;
donc il y aurait quelqu'un
qui créerait un monde
dans lequel on évolue,
t pas vrai.
- Dans "La Matrice", le héros
doit choisir entre la pilule
bleue et la pilule rouge.
La pilule bleu est celle
de la réalité et
la pilule rouge est celle de
la volonté d'apprendre
la vérité : que l'humain est
l'esclave est machine.
Cette image a été maintes fois
récupéré parfois à tord
et à travers.
HERVÉIS, Prof. médias
émergent Univ. Québec Chicoutimi
- La Matrice a ouvert la porte
à une espèce de pensée simpliste
à un certain niveau aussi où
c'est facile de dire : Oh,
on est tous plugués dans
une machine; ce n'est pas grave.
Ou il n'ui existe,
n'est pas vrai; où il n'y a pas
de conséquences sur ce qu'on
fait. C'est facile de faire
des affirmations comme ça.
mier film "La Matrice"
est sorti en 1999, soit 5 ans
avant la création de la méta-
plateforme numérique Facebook.
- (extrait film): J'ai fait
des rêves qui n'étaient pas que
des rêves.
- En 2021, la Matrice a quelque
chose de bien réel et ils seront
nombreux à voir la suite
baptisé : "La Matrice :
réssurection".
Ici Louis-Philipp
Radio-Canada, Montréal.